[Music]
that is the latest single from las
vegas's own elvis monroe
the song is called one day someday and
they co-wrote it
with country singer brett young earlier
i spoke with the guys about how the song
came to be
kind of crazy we were out with daughtry
of doing some shows and we were in
oregon
and we get a call from brett young and
he was out with ada
and on a day off we met up at a little
bar in beaver creek oregon and he talked
us into doing some karaoke
literally until the guy in the back of
the room yelled out let somebody else
sing
and when that happened i just witnessed
a conversation between
brent and his then girlfriend who is now
his
wife and having their second baby um and
we
i put in my phone and he caught me and
he goes no man
he goes here it is it's one day someday
now let's write it and so about two days
later bank came up with some music on
the bus and we started bouncing it back
and forth
and it was actually off the right before
october 1 here in las vegas september
31st i think here at 30th
um i brought the demo to
brett and ben because ben was playing
guitar with him and
yeah and then we just started working
out from there and that on october 1 i
actually met by one day sunday
so do you guys see any live shows
upcoming live shows any touring give us
the update on that
we have about five shows booked uh we're
going up to uh alaska and oregon
coming up over the next few months
california is in california
and we do have some talks little
whispers right now
returning to a monthly residency here in
vegas which is what actually started
elvis monroe we'd all flying from our
tours
and um we kind of want to get back to
our roots since this is a
new and improved version we want to get
back to what what we love and
what what this wants to do is get in
front of the people here in our hometown
all right alice monroe is their new
album competing with giants is due out
this summer